good evening everyone welcome to the
Columbia so art man technology lectures
this semester focusing on open source
culture the intersection of intellectual
property technology and the arts this
series is organized by the digital media
center here at the School of the Arts in
collaboration with the computer Music
Center and also the Center for new media
teaching and learning which is producing
the website where you can find streaming
video for all of the previous lectures
and you can find that just by googling
Columbia art and Technology lectures
it's with great pleasure that I welcome
Cory Arcangel tonight he's the fifth
speaker in our series this semester Cory
is a computer artist whose work is
compute concerned with technology's
relationship to culture and creativity
he's a founding member of beige which is
a group of computer programmers and
enthusiasts who recycle obsolete
computers and video game systems game
boyse etc and make art and music with
them he's also a member of our SG
radical software group which is a
collaborative group of artists who've
done a bunch of projects mostly online
including carnivore which many of you
may be familiar with Cory's work has
been exhibited in a lot of places
recently at the Whitney Biennial at the
Whitney Museum of American Art the
Museum of Modern Art the Guggenheim
Museum he's represented by team gallery
here in New York he has shown at Tate
Britain
foxie productions it's quite a long list
it is with great pleasure that I welcome
Cory Arcangel
thank you
all right so here's okay
this is my outline for the talk today
and here this is what I'm going to talk
about so I'll first I'll go through a
quick overview and for those of you have
seen my talks is for this one is gonna
be a little bit different and a little
bit more focused
hopefully cuz Mark had he's you know we
were talking he's like you know you do
something in your artwork yeah he's like
sometimes you recycle code you know yeah
he's like I think that's interesting and
I was like oh I do and I was like oh
yeah I guess I do sometimes and so the
umbrella of this talk is different ways
to recycle code and well not only to
recycle code and I also wanted to make
it a little broader how in some of my
projects are either will reuse code or
steal code that's a better way to put it
or reuse or steal aesthetics and so it's
kind of like my interest in how computer
software and computer code all have
their own aesthetic and just a lot of my
work deals with mucking around within
those within that aesthetic and stuff
like that so so I picked out a couple
problem a couple projects I think like
seven or eight that deal with those
topics and I tried to arrange them in a
way that makes sense
first I'm going to talk about how I got
started doing this kind of stuff and it
talked a little bit about my work with
beige and that's how I got heavily
involved in this computer stuff and then
we're going to go through some projects
and the first thing we're going to talk
about is this project I did called data
diaries which is the project where I
just kind of reinterpret some code that
I found lying around and then we're
going to talk about projects that I
actually steal code from different
sources and turn them into our work most
notably video games and then after that
I wanted to show you a few things that I
do when I'm not screwing around with
computers to give you an idea of like
a general overview of my work this
doesn't make any sense now but hopefully
it'll make sense when I'm doing it and
then I wanted to talk about a project I
did called the infinite filled zone that
deals with using US anesthetic stolen
from a certain piece of software and and
then I wanted to talk about my work with
IBM gorg which deals with a bunch of
stuff a bunch of silly internet projects
that deal with page scraping which is a
technique where you just kind of scrape
all the data off of a website and
interpret it and then kind of throw it
back anyway I'll explain it in a bit so
why don't we start off with the first
thing when I wasn't when I am I went to
college at the Overland Conservatory of
Music and I went to college to study
classical guitar and oh also at any time
I don't I don't want to keep talking so
if you guys have any questions or
anything or anything's confusing just
raise your hand or just shout out right
because if I just keep talking out it
I'll lose myself dude I mean so we got
to keep this moving
do you know what I mean and yeah so I'll
be ok anyway ok so I went so I went
there and that was really when I first
got pretty heavy into computer art and
basically about two years into the
program and it was a pretty heavy-duty
I still so sand from this booth ring
sorry it was a pretty heavy duty a
typical classical education right so I
had the practice guitar all day long and
it was just a normal conservator
education and a couple years into it
like a lot of conservatory students I
got really really really burnt out and
kind of had a breakdown or whatever and
flipped out and just at the same time
got a heavy interest in computers now I
was always a computer nerd I was like
way into the Bard's Tale and like you
know like computer games or whatever but
I never had learned how to program until
I went to college and the reason I
wanted to learn how to program initially
initially is because after having being
trained as a class of big guitarists I
had no skills at all and so I was like
I'm going to be graduating from college
and you know you
for two years and I have not even an
ounce of a skill do you know I mean so I
was like it was a practical decision at
first to learn computers you know what I
mean but as I learned computers and I
had all this excess energy from not
playing guitar six hours a day I got
pretty heavy into it and it was around
this time I started collaborating with a
person who have worked with for a number
of years named Paul B Davis and we
started a record label together called
beige records and it was in these early
collaborations with Paul that kind of
formed my my artistic look at computers
and we had done a lot of talking in
those days and that was the days of the
beginning beginnings of when media arts
started to hit pretty heavy in in kind
of liberal arts colleges you know and so
everyone was screwing on computers and
we just did a lot of talking and just
basically for whatever reason cornered
ourselves into a hole just being like
you know you gotta know how to program
and if you're not programming you're a
poser and I don't necessarily believe
this today but at the at that time I was
kind of a punk you know what I mean and
I was always like yo you know and so we
formed a record label called beige
records and it kind of it kind of acted
somewhat as a record label and also
somewhat as like a crew you know what I
mean like step two step two beige I mean
it was ridiculous but but you know
whatever we were 19 or whatever so and
so I want to show you the first project
and I always I always talk about this
project of my lectures because I think
it was a really important project for me
and the other kids in beige and so the
first thing I wanted to talk about whoa
so we had a techno record label right
and we released techno records for a
couple years and they were received with
mix you know they were received well and
it was also the birth of eBay and Paul
as I mentioned got heavy into eBay this
was pre IPO eBay and you know like
everybody when they first learned about
eBay they just have like a spaz out that
drains them of a couple hundred bucks
and for Paul it happened to drain him of
a couple hundred bucks on Ataris and so
our dorm room started to fill up with
these old Atari computers and at a
certain point we just had kind of a
flash mob idea we were like
well if we're gonna release another
techno record let's let's do a record
but let's make it on these old computers
right and so we came up with this record
it's called the 8-bit Construction Set
and yeah so basically the concept is
that we made one side on the Commodore
64 home computer right and we made the
other side on the Atari 800 home
computer and these are you know early
eighties Mac and PC you know I mean it
was like these are the two computers
that people had that then people would
argue about which was cooler right and
so basically the idea of this record
it's actually a DJ battle record so it's
them it was it's like it's it's for DJ's
you know like everybody familiar with
scratch DJ battles okay anyway okay so
it just starts off like the record
starts off with scratch taupe scratch
tones so sounds for DJ's to scratch with
and then mock grooves which are infinite
repeating loops and then a track like
just like a straight up club track you
know what I mean and then data which is
like a lot of people forget that before
floppy drives were commercially
available computers used to store
programs on cassette tape as audio files
and so these tracks on the end of the
record are programs for the Commodore
and the Atari that you could then load
onto cassette tape and then load and
execute into your computer and so it's
also this record is also in a way a
software distribution and so we were
really happy about that and while we
were making this record basically yes
yes questions good very good I love it
yeah
ah good question on the Commodore side
is the cool the cool side each side has
three different sections one is a shout
outs which is like shout outs to all our
peeps you know and just a list of all
our friends and whatever in fact I don't
know whatever and a video like well we
would refer to as a post data video
which is another ridiculous term we
invented back then but I'll show you an
example
in a second oops now I'm ruining the
webcast sorry so it's basically just a
noise video like don't colors and it's
going crazy and the third part is Sid
303 which is a program written by
another member of beige named Joe Boykin
which is a a rollin 303 emulator for the
Commodore 64 do all you know what the
role in 303 synthesizer is should I play
an example of what a rollin 303 sounds
like okay hold on while my iTunes loads
up roland is rollin 303 is synthesizer
is a synthesizer that bird bird the acid
house and so here I'll play heavy acid
riding which is a track that Paul and I
actually made in our band the acid heads
and this is what a 303 sounds like here
right right hold on yo anyway that make
any sense at all
it's like acid house was like this
version of house music was this one
synthesizer it just made this one
particular noise and we were heavy
techno nerds and to a certain extent
still and I still am a heavy techno nerd
but so yeah this is a program on the
camera that's was supposedly to emulate
that kind of sound which is just
ridiculous but and the Atari side does
essentially the same thing but it's not
quite as involved so does that yeah so
that's what it would do to answer Mark's
question are there any questions about
this I should also say that there's four
people and it took us about two and a
half years to make it and it was in this
time that we got really heavy-duty into
learning how to program these old
computers question oh that's a real I
don't think so many people did like a
couple kids I think got the Atari side
and you'd have to ask my my friend Paul
this and I think maybe one kid got the
Commodore side but it has a problem
because you have to do it right when you
buy the record or it gets scratched you
know I mean yeah but we had it on our
website too
three thousand and we just repress them
actually if you want to go get them at
turntable lab in the East Village you're
welcome to and they're usually sold
pretty cheap like seven bucks or
something old-school prices so let me
pass it out any other questions so yeah
it was four members Joe Boyd and Jo bond
Paul Davidson me and so this was our
little group and it was also the time
that we got heavily involved in
programming those olds these old
computers and learning how they worked
and that really got me started on making
this stupid well that's - I'm gonna
someone wants to meet Cory don't call
your work stupid but I after years and
years I still do this awesome computer
stuff that I do here you hear you could
pass it around
there's some funny stuff in the record I
also use this record as a folder so let
me take out all my paper there is some
funny like stuff oh here's the sheet
that tells you how to load the data into
the into the how to load the data from
the record to your computer with a nice
little don't with us that was our
kind of slogan here that and 8 bits for
life biatch which is like totally I
would anyway like I said we were pretty
young anyway so but that came out in
2001 so that's pretty old but it kind of
really set the pace for me to making
this computer stuff so around that time
I was also got into programming one to
make like to screw on that kind of
computers into the first kind of
heavy-duty computer art I made that debt
was code was just to play pranks on
people in my school and so I just oh let
me so I so I just wanted to like for
instance I the first like big thing I
remember doing in doing by taking apart
a program and disassembling it and
reassembling it was it it was back in
when I went to school kids we had a
public computer lab and everyone used
that lab to check their email and they
needed to use a program called telnet
which you know now I think you probably
have like some online system or whatever
and so you'd have to open up telnet and
and so I
I disassembled it does everyone know
what disassembling means like all
programs on computer are a star this is
where this I'm you guys have to help me
here our data that's been compiled for
the machine right and it's just a bunch
of ones and zeros and the funny thing
that a lot of people don't know is you
could then disassemble that and then it
becomes into sort of a language that you
could understand and then you can go
futzing with all of that and then
reassemble it and then it will do
something a little bit different and so
the first thing I did was I made a mail
program that I would install on all the
computers at school so when you went
when kids went to check their mail the
computer would shut down and the cd-rom
drive it open and I thought that was the
greatest thing ever because he I could
just kind of like sit at one computer
and pretend like I was working and some
kid would sit down and be like and then
they would be like you know and then go
anyway so that was the first thing I
ever - anyway but point I'm trying to
make is around this time is when I was
starting to heavy-duty futz with
computers and take apart and see how
operating systems works how operating
systems worked and stuff like that and
then I started to make art and so the
project I want to show now is a project
that oh wait maybe next is low level all
starship oh wait well hmm should I show
a little of all stars all right well let
me show the project called data diaries
see this is gonna be hard for you
because I'm going to skip all around so
you listen okay well actually yeah let's
ok can you not do that DVD that's in
there so let's cancel that DVD I wanted
to show a program called a project
called dated ours which I did recently
but it was an idea I thought of years
ago around the same time and let me go
to the website I'll show it off the web
to you our bul huh what what is there a
Mike oh yeah sure
well this is my delicious feed this is
my this is my page this is out by
accident by the way it's like I have a
page of links that I put up every day
when I cause I'm a heavy heavy heavy web
surfer like four packs a day four
web surfing and so someone and this is
that this is the first time it ever
happened someone emailed me and they're
like yo dude right on awesome link page
and I was my first fan PAP fan mail for
my links page which was awesome and he
emailed me this he's like this is my
present because you have such cool links
and let's see if it works
oh I hope they didn't take it down okay
so the guy obviously understands that
I'm interested and then we'll talk about
this later my my word for this kind of
design is called dirt style but this is
high-end dirt style dirt style meaning
just the nastiest do you I mean but this
is obviously like dirt style with a lot
of well actually I'm gonna I'm gonna
move so just I'm sorry all the people
watching this online I got to get out of
the camera okay just look at this like
obviously Photoshop clone tool like
that's great you know what I mean this
is what I'm interested in this is just
like someone went I mean god I don't
know what what was happening okay but I
just surf all day and we could talk
later about at the end of the lecture
I'm gonna get into how all my art now is
basically just like that stuff but just
yeah like bad stuff for the the web and
you see that my link from last night was
a link to old Macintosh browsers which I
have running on my computer here and
netscape 1.0 which I made the lecture
notes in today which I decided I was
like man I love the bling tag it'd be so
funny if I put the entire webpage in
between a blink tag and that's why the
whole webpage is blinking anyway okay
data diary
sorry I got sidetracked this see this is
oh this is always what happens be you
alien seed oh okay so why I wanted to
show dated ours is because this is an
example of just this came out of that
phase when I was fussing around in
school in the public lab and I did this
other thing that I used to call called
um RAM fishing and so what people don't
know is that the random access processor
of a computer never gets erased it just
gets overwritten until the computer is
turned off and so what that means is
that if you have a computer in
public lab or at least then when you had
a computer in the public lab it's the
computer is on all day and there's 10
people using that computer all their
junk was sitting in the random access
memory trip of the computer meaning if
they were writing a paper it would get
loaded into RAM and when they quit the
program most likely parts of that paper
were still in RAM and when they are
writing emails the same thing so I used
to go Ram phishing which was I'd sit
down at a computer in the public lab and
just fish through a ram for Strings and
see what people had left behind and it
was kind of a way for me to to just
giggle a little bit and then and this
project comes out of that because I I
was then started screwing with the
QuickTime file format and I learned that
it was a funny thing you could do with a
QuickTime file cook time is like a movie
file on a computer right and see it
stopped me if this gets too technical
I wanted this talk to be a little bit
technical all right ok anyway basically
what I would do is I would have a movie
on the harddrive right and then a file
on the macintosh a-- at the time was
organized in two parts one the part of
the file called the header which told
the computer what was about to happen
the header says look computer this is a
movie it's going to be two minutes long
it's going to be in 16 colors and it's
going to have an audio track right and
the second part of the file is the data
which then that header will read through
right and so I found by accident that if
you delete the data and you double-click
on the file
it had a QuickTime didn't have any error
checking so it would be like cool we're
gonna have a movie it's gonna be five
minutes long it's gonna be 16 colors and
then it would just play whatever is in
the RAM because they had no I had no
idea and the way I found out about this
was by accident is you know I just I
just downloaded a movie and I just
forced quit right after I downloaded it
you don't I mean and then I found out
how it happened and so the I eventually
ended up doing a project called data
diaries out of that which basically what
I did was I made a movie out of my RAM
for every day of the month and so does
that make sense so every day it changes
because god knows what I did that day
and so I made 31 movies each one for the
day of the month and so I made a website
for it so let's watch the movies but I
can wider color
okay what day what day did we like okay
27 Ron hacksaws number any hockey fans
in the house Ron Hextall come on oh I
went into the wrong field
he was the goalie for the Philadelphia
Flyers who had a bad temper problem and
would often skate out of his net and
like chop people and he was also like I
think the highest school in Gore goalie
ever because he would take slap shots
and wing them off the glass and it would
bounce into the net very talented man
huh you're an Islander fan so you're
like quit it with the Ron Hextall talk
okay
yeah let's get back to the computer art
please all right so here's the 27th Oh
perfect so this is what I mean you know
it was just I just said like look it's
gonna be 16 colors and it's gonna be 11
minutes long so it's a haul all 128
megabytes of my RAM let's skip ahead a
little bit oh this is what happens when
the computer crashes and it resets the
RAM so my kid let's see if oh this is
the cool part hold on
oh man there we go what's up reset oh
there we go but the thing you should I
should know about this is I basically
didn't do anything you know what I mean
that was so it was cool about this
project it was like totally low stress
and for those of you taking notes it's
on turbulence it was a commissioned by
turbulence which is a place that
commissions by Bart and still to this
day so yeah this is what happened my
computer obviously crashed emails
whatever so does that make sense so all
the days look basically similar let's go
to a different date one more day anybody
okay oh I said that I had a sound I just
said that it had a sound file in it and
so it's just okay that date is there's
data there's sound data there too right
like it just basically the entire
project came down to what the header was
and the way I designed the header was
what would what would be just enough for
people to see in real time over a 56k
modem and so it ended up being a movie
this size with this sound file and so it
was kind of like half determined by the
restrictions of the web and I guess half
determined I don't yeah that's it oh
that looks cool
yeah question oh no because because the
QuickTime movie would have to have been
the same the same size of this and this
actually the trick about this is that
this is actually a quicktime movie about
that big that I'm just blowing up on the
website well I do get sounds if sounds
are uncompressed you could hear like
like if I made something on Pro Tools
that day you would hear all the samples
in Pro Tools and stuff like that so
never video but sound because sound is
often stored uncompressed on a computer
does that make sense no the actual movie
is about this big and what I'm doing on
the website is I'm stretching it and so
that's why it it loads so quickly
because it's really tiny and this I mean
if I would make it again today the movie
the pixels would be smaller because
vanitha today is a lot that's cool so it
was a fun project because I would just
do it every day and then sit and watch
it I'd be like oh cool
I'll be like go me or whatever okay so
yeah I wanted to show that because that
I'm trying to keep this talk under
control and that's an example just
basically just using data that's lying
around as art projects right like
garbage I mean it's essentially garbage
okay so next the part of the talk that I
want to get into is getting more into
the disassembly and talking about
Nintendo modifications which is another
thing that I do quite a bit and I wanted
to talk about the four different kind of
a Nintendo modifications and see if I
could make them make any sense the first
one I wanted to talk about oh is Hogan's
Alley perfect okay so around the same
time after the record was done Paul and
I started making Nintendo cartridges and
we learned that you could take apart oh
yeah perfect wow thank you okay oh but
this is we're not supposed to see this
yet
yeah sorry that's that's that's three
projects no no you could keep it on a
Nintendo okay so that you could take
apart a Nintendo cartridges and there's
two chips inside of it and one is a
program chip and one is a graphics chip
and essentially a video game the program
chip tells the graphics to move around
and that's what becomes the game right
and so by soldering different chips into
back into these cartridges I've done a
lot of projects which kind of just screw
with video games in different ways some
of them are where I just changed the
graphics of a video game which is called
a graphics hack which is very easy and I
hope that you guys could come away with
this lecture knowing that it isn't so
hard to do another kind of hack is a
program hack where you keep the graphics
of the game the same but you tell them
to do different things and the third
kind of hack I wanted to talk about is
where you just basically barely do
anything to the game and keep it the
same and not that's what I'm into right
now which is kind of a little bit too
obscure I think but that's okay and then
the fourth kind of hack of a Nintendo
game is just by writing something from
scratch and but I wanted to talk about
the first thing is graphics hacks so
basically you just leave the program of
the game alone and you switch the
graphics and so basically you're just
appropriating the program code from a
game and it's quite common and you could
do it to most games you'd be surprised
how many games are able to be modified
so just so you guys know that you should
look into it
Wolfenstein is the easiest to learn I
found out kapha Wolfenstein on the Mac
and Jody did a famous piece the artist
Jody org called I think it was untitled
do you untitled or s OD
anyway SOT yeah and so um well let me
show you this hack and so this is the
hack of the game called Hogan's Alley
and what I in Hogan's Alley is one of
those shoot-'em-up games and what I did
was called change it to I shot Andy
Warhol and so essentially I just changed
all the graphics graphics around right
okay
oh good okay so and then in a second in
a second you'll see the characters and
so I put you have to shoot the Warhol's
and then of course I switch the bottom
guys a self-explanatory to the Pope
Flavor Flav and Colonel Santa's and so
the game acts just like normal and I I
think I I think I could get it to play I
can't shoot because the gun doesn't work
on a projector it only works on a TV but
you can see what the game looks like
self-explanatory okay anyway I'll show
you what up there's other parts to the
game there's the city section obviously
the same thing but it's in a city and
there's the soup shot which when you're
making a game modification or you're
taking code you're taking compiled code
and you can't really change how the game
works right and so there's so many
limited there's a there's a lot of
limitations and so the the clincher of
why I made an I shot with andy warhol
game as opposed to shoot the Pope or
shoot fat Alveston out skinny Elvis is
because that the third part of this game
this is exactly how it was originally
can so you know what I mean so I was
like oh it's too perfect you know I mean
I don't even have to do anything to the
last part and it still makes sense so
that's a secret for you but it's a good
example of that when you work with like
appropriating like the code from a video
game that you have these really intense
limitations you have to work with well
that doesn't take that long I mean
actually well perfect question because
I've prepared for that the only a hard
part about that problem that was it's
not so hard to switch the graphics on a
graphics chip the hard part was the
limitations of the of the ROM and so
okay now who do I put in I've got 32 by
52 pixels you know what I mean
who the hell is going to be recognizable
in 32 by 52 pixels you'd be surprised
how many people that cancels out like
Pamela Anderson which I tried at some
point let me see
just look like some of the girl with a
bikini on oh Jesus
doesn't even work let's see
so yeah the hard part about that game
was determining who were the most
recognizable pop figures who actually
were alive in the last 100 years that
would work and that small oh so here's
Jesus and the reason the reason Jesus
didn't work was because he's he had to
get the cross in he had to be smaller
than the rest of the characters so it's
like Jesus is not really even
recognizable as just a guy he just looks
like a skinny guy with a little
loincloth you don't I mean so there are
these like the the hardest part about
that particular project was just kind of
dealing with the culture do you not I
mean whereas the game hack wasn't so
hard that there was one tiny game hack
thing is that the a lot of the
characters didn't have the same symmetry
like Flavor Flav has his hat to the side
which means I needed to find out the the
bit in the program that dealt with the
symmetry of the characters and that was
the only kind of hard part I almost
didn't do it because I couldn't figure
out yes oh it's just a little machine
called an EEPROM burner which is just
like a cd-rom burner for computer chips
and they're cheap because a lot of
people like to hotrod their Nissan's now
and it just for some reason it takes the
same chip so when I go by my EEPROM it's
like this works great in the nissan
ultra but I don't play underneath I know
what they're talking about so it's just
like a CD you know so it's it's it's not
you know it just takes a little
soldering and I hate doing anything in
my hands so if I could do it really
anybody could do it like I really hate I
really hate it do you know I mean like I
yeah you know that's what I'm a computer
artist but it's one thing that I'm
willing to do anyway are there any other
questions let me show you I'll show you
Pamela Anderson and I tried Ponce or
officer ponch some tips and that didn't
work at all you so that's Pamela
Anderson it's just like doesn't really
make any sense you know like it doesn't
really make any sense so yeah yeah she
is symmetrical oh yeah and then first
awhile I was like oh what maybe the pea
don't actually have to be real people
maybe they could be you know like
characters from beaker or whatever so
anyway I wonder if I should show low
level all-stars how long I have an hour
right I got a key oh okay that's max so
I shouldn't push it so I'll go quick
okay twenty minutes do it do it okay
let's do it
can you put in that first DVD I showed
you real quick when I was making this
8-bit record yes I learned about this
scene called cracking like cracking and
basically it's started on the Commodore
64 and when kids would when video games
were available on the floppy disk for
the Commodore 64 kids would crack them
and then this evolved this this kind of
thing evolved and eventually they would
put their names on the front of the
games they cracked by whatever yo Han
from Finland or whatever and then and
then they started getting into gangs and
cracking games together and then making
these elaborate audio-visual
introductions to games they cracked and
this was a huge thing for me when I
started making computer art because I
just thought that was the most pure
expression that I it's basically
graffiti but it's up for computer nerds
you know cuz you're basically tagging
software and this was like when I first
learned about that was when I was doing
all this stuff at school and that was
the thing that really made me and still
to this day makes me the most excited oh
um can you skip one or one or two I
think there might be something wrong
with this DVD oh okay yeah play and skip
like a couple ahead just your discretion
okay let's yeah okay whatever just play
whatever one and so basically a lot of
calm these are all cracks intros for
Commodore games and a lot of them are
available on long and me and a friend
Alex Galloway who is the head of the
radical software group look through a
bunch of them and pick the ones that
we'd like the best and this is an
example of one by a group called crack
force Amiga and I thought this was
really beautiful and so basically you
get this video game and it's been
cracked by this kid and this is the
introduction he makes and this is the
kind of stuff that I think was just I
just think it's great you know
any questions
let's go a couple more head will do one
more yeah people still do and people do
it with software because I learned about
it on Pro Tools like when I use Pro
Tools in college I saw some kid had it
and there was a snowman with a black bar
over his eyes as the intro and I was
like whoa this is a crib called Fair
light which was very very famous and
this how about that right they're still
around right what do they do now like
high-end graphics are still cracking
yeah this guy I ended up getting in
touch with and he had said that this
particular intro didn't get much play in
the day because it wasn't flashy enough
but Alex and I thought it was the
greatest thing we'd ever seen in our
life so ok that's good for that just we
gotta just had to do we had to show that
big influence but those are kids that
are basically piggybacking on software
you know what I mean which i think is
amazing and it's not so different from
what I do
ok next hack let's do the opposite well
let's see what else did I bring another
project I did was called super mario
clouds and that's almost the exact
opposite in super mario clouds
I stole the graphics and I just
basically erased the program code so
it's it's the opposite of the Warhol
does that make sense
and so basically let's see mm-hmm I just
have a row I don't have the actual
cartridge here so it just looks like
that so it's just basically the clouds
from the Mario Brothers game so when you
put in the cartridge to just scroll
forever and that was pretty easy to do
yes show an installation shot so how do
I install this what is it is it a video
is it installation dot dot this is how
usual I install it and it's very
important the installation is very
important this is a high-res pitcher so
give it a second but it was what I made
I made the Warhol in the clouds
basically at the same time and I made
the oh so this is what I
it usually looks like when it's
installed and so there's a couple
projectors and as many projectors as you
can give me I do and it's supposed to be
like a picnic it supposed to be like a
place where you'd like to take a picnic
well that's all I like to think of it
like you just anyway does that make
sense but I when I did this project
because I had done some the graphic
Warhol thing and I thought well be funny
not to change the graphics of the game
you know what I mean it'd be funny just
to leave the graphic chip untouched on
the Nintendo cuz then you get into this
weird area like it's not even a copy do
you know I mean it's like the clouds
that I'm projecting are the real clouds
and like that to me was like the essence
of what I'm trying to do like it's kind
of like a rebellion against design
culture and high-end computer culture
it's like okay it's just the clouds and
it's like a very iconic image but like
those are the real clouds dude I mean
it's like I'm those are the real clouds
you don't mean I mean I don't know how
to say it the best way I could say it is
you know step to that oh this is going
terrible no how did I are there any
questions so that's a very simple and
around that time my work and we could
talk up I'm gonna try to my work got
simpler and simpler and it's just
getting simpler and simpler because I
like to do things that are really easy
and at that time I didn't have much
exhibition opportunity and so I made a
web page for that and how to make it you
know here's the source code and here's
how I made it
download it make it yourself it's cool
and I had you know hoped that it would
participate in a web culture and it
ended up doing it did you know cuz all I
hate here's a kid who did this thing
with a Mario thing you know so that was
kind of one of the original impetuses to
do that to do that project what was I
trying to say yeah okay third example is
oh this this one is ridiculous so now
what I like to do is I like to change
the game as least as possible like
what's the littlest thing I could do to
a game to make it into some kind of art
okay
so this is a new one that I just did and
I'm very proud of it and it's called
super slow Tetris and and basically
all's it is is a Tetris but it runs
super slow and I was very proud about
this because this isn't really a
graphics hack and it's hardly a program
hack and I didn't even disassemble the
game to do it so I just basically what I
did is I opened up the ROM in binary and
I wrote a little thing at the end that
said because that all old computer games
synced to the television screen and I
just said hey why don't we sync to every
three times the electron goes on the TV
instead of every one you don't I mean so
it's just a tiny little waiter at the
beginning in the code and I I show the
code actually here oh oh can we go to
the computer and then we'll go back to
the Nintendo sorry okay oh I got to put
it in because it takes so long to get
going that we might we might not
actually see anything so this is what it
looks like so I just added and this is
just a couple ones and zeros I added to
the end of the ROM and so anyway it's
really nerdy but I was very proud of it
because I it's just like what is the
littlest thing you could do to a video
game that would make it cool okay we
could go back to the Nintendo but I'm
not gonna promise anybody hear anything
because okay let's see now the original
game makes you wait on the screen for
like 15 seconds and mine makes you wait
on the screen for a really long time so
let's give it like 45 seconds and if it
doesn't get over well this will let it
maybe we'll come back to it let's come
back to that because it's got to sit for
a while because it's really slow okay
well just okay what else do I want to
talk about oh wait okay oh I can't talk
about my next intent of thing until we
show that oh well let's skip ahead stuff
I do when not screwing with computers
okay maybe let's skip that because we're
short on time okay
oh no QA let's ax the QA and let's show
this video okay perfect idea can you put
in the one the one that says beach boys
versus ghetto boys so I wanted to give
an example of the things I do when not
screwing with computers because
basically I'm hoping you're giving an
idea that most everything I do is just
stealing stuff right a week is that are
we getting that and it's not it's not
it's not because I'm trying to make a
political statement it's not because I'm
trying to do I'm not trying to be a
hacker or activist or anything just
because it's just because as Mark put it
interesting in conversation the other
day it's like that says it's the air you
breathe and it's just like you know like
me being 26 or whatever like I just
don't know anything else you know I mean
like I have I have no nothing in my mind
it has any significance unless it's like
attached to some kind of culture or pop
culture thing does that make sense
anyway so this is a video called the
beach boys versus the ghetto boys and
it's just the video for the Beach Boys
six feet deep and then in a second the
weight that's the ghetto boys and then
in a second
the Beach Boys little surfer girl is
going to come on and so all that adhere
was just play the two videos side by
side and I just wanted to play it as an
example the other stuff I made which
hopefully it would give you the idea
that all it's all the same really
whether it's a computer or not computer
just gotta wait a sec
okay the Beach Boys songs are shorter
because pop music back then the songs
were shorter so just ride it out for a
little while but well through the Beach
Boys little surfer girls like two and a
half minutes which is insane
think of how short that is it's like an
intro for a song now maybe a little V
there we go so this isn't I always think
that this project I made essentially the
same time at the same time I did the
tetris thing and I always think that
they're not so much different like here
I barely did anything and Tetris I
barely did anything so my process is
just basically solely degrading in to
where I'm not gonna do anything I'm just
gonna give people videos music videos
from the 80s or something alright you
could turn that off is there any
questions about that
yes that I did do and that that was a
huge thing for me I didn't know if I
should do that but I did I slowed one of
them down a tad
and then I pitched one a little bit in
the beginning because the Beach Boys
modulates half us half step halfway
through which is really weird but and
that obviously is heavy internet surfing
inspired you know what I mean I wanted
to do a mashup like on the internet but
I didn't want to actually edit it like I
just wanted to put two things side by
side and then there was a whole process
of like new order new addition to life
crew motley crue you know like finding
something that would work together
finally I lucked out that those and I
bought lots of DVDs so alright so the
next thing appropriating aesthetics and
I wanted to show a little thing the
project I did called the infinite fill
zone and no let's do pizza party for
weight hmm yeah okay infinite filled
zone and so as well as just like
stealing code or whatever I also just
like software you know I mean really
ghetto software and so about a year ago
I got heavy-duty into this program
called lightning paint and lightning
paint is a clone of Mac Paint and we all
remember Mac Paint right anybody well
Mac paint looked like this it was the
first graphical like Photoshop type
application for Macintosh and it looks
like this hey cool and you get to do
things like this and you get to like
really cool stuff like this and the very
very important part of this software is
the paint bucket which allows you to
fill patterns and basically because
since this program was in black and
white
it couldn't you couldn't feel color and
so oh wow so basically you have all
these patterns and so I really got very
heavy into this and did a show this
summer called the infinite Phil show or
ask people hey if you have artwork
that's black and white and has patterns
in it let's do an art show together and
so this is what that ended up a looking
like there ended up being 93 artists
cool right
it looks like big mac paint and so I
don't know why did it except I just love
the way that that software looks and I
think every software has an aesthetic
and like even though at one point I was
like you can't use software to make art
because you're a poser you know what I
mean you've got to write your software
and now I'm a little bit more
open-minded like well you can use
software and as long as you're aware of
the aesthetic that the software imposes
just like jump to dive right in because
it's awesome do you know what I mean and
so anyway like for instance my lecture
notes isn't a good example of diving
right into HTML circa 1995 you know what
I mean and I call this dirt style design
anyway okay what was I going to show
next huh oh let's go back to Tetris good
idea I don't know oh great okay
yeah it's just ridiculous right I'm
pressing down it should move its I don't
remember how long I set it for but in my
it might just come on there we go
so like endurance video anybody woo yeah
that's the project it's infuriating it's
unplayable like I don't know where it's
going you know what I mean but I like it
just like you just leave it on and just
let it roll you don't I mean because
eventually it's gonna kill itself but
it'll probably play like it'll probably
take like eight hours or something if
you don't I mean so any questions are
continuing on super slow Tetris well I
know there was the artist Douglas Gordon
who I loved did 24 hour psycho which
which he rigged a projector up to go to
play that movie 24 hours and I thought I
was like Dan as awesome oh I don't know
somebody somebody somebody who knows
something about art talk once through
yeah it's a beautiful idea yeah yeah and
and John Simon his John Simon the
computer artist did every icon which
also will take and so there's a whole
history of this this I would I think is
a little bit stupider but that's right
where I am right now you know what I
mean okay well thank you for reminding
me about that let's talk about the iPod
another Nintendo thing which is
basically just appropriating the sound
of the Nintendo do you want to pass this
around here we could pass around but I
like the idea of doing touches because
it's a game worth more time is obviously
the most
and it's frustrating and I hate Tetris
so can we go back to the Nintendo this
is a project I did just called nine pod
iPod I don't you can call whatever you
want it's just basically an iPod for the
Nintendo Entertainment System and I just
put in all these cool songs Oh could we
have a little vm on the olden Nintendo
maybe I knocked it out did I knock it
out it should be sending there we go
are there any requests no no not Judas
Priest foot Noda Oh a new owner and
Weezer okay just the popular part of the
song I would add Weezer is the whole
song because I determined that the
entire song is the popular part of the
song so this was written from scratch
and it also has a DJ function you know
so if I just want the melody or just the
drums or just the bass and the guitar
and the drums right or the bass in the
melody right does that make sense
so anyway
so this is kind of like a performance to
which kind of strays for most of my work
because I usually hate doing things from
scratch you don't I mean like I just cuz
I don't think it gives people enough to
latch on to but you got it you got to go
with it sometimes no the Nintendo has a
built-in sounded chip and I'm just
poking the appropriate numbers into the
sound chip yeah it's not MIDI it's it's
it's just proprietary to the Nintendo
hardware I should point out that that's
very important part of working on the
Nintendo is that you have to essentially
work directly with the hardware yeah
yeah insecurity no no go ahead right
right right
so are you you're asking is is is just
laziness like a factor in the work huh
that's a very good question
let me think am i lazy artist I like I
like the idea of being belligerent or
something like like appearing careless
do you and I mean like they're hangin in
there but I don't think I'm lazy so I
think my question is half yes in half no
does that make sense like I like like
when I get a new piece of software or
like or like a flash if I'm dying to
make something on flash you know and I
just want to get in there and just like
yeah be this lazy and messy and make it
terrible you don't I mean and like but
it to me that's just like just letting
the software beat me up and I'm
interested in that right and so and I'm
just interested in the same way way with
my other work is just like
that cultural stuff punched me around a
bit anyway I don't even know if that was
an answer but I hope it's a good answer
but I'm just like I like working with
stuff because it just is the only stuff
that makes sense to me and it's also the
stuff that people can understand the
most easily and then the last thing I
wanted to talk about is oh wait okay and
then we can maybe play this video okay
is pizza party in my work with i-beam
gorg and I work in a group there called
the contagious media group and we're a
research and development group that
would studies the phenomenon of web
memes and it's the idea in a web meme as
a meme as a an idea that spreads itself
you know in a web meme is a good example
of a web meme it's like some kind of
email that you get while you're at work
someone hey check this out and we're you
know all your base are belong to us
isn't good or remember that homepage of
that guy who lived in Eastern Europe and
he's like or the first one I remember
was mr. t ate my balls does anyone
remember that huge web meme and then
like never mind that's not it hamster
dance ok let's start it everyone's like
nobody remembers that come on 96 anyway
so we studied that and I think that's a
big reason why a lot of my work
appropriates things is because that's
the kind of language that those things
end up using often or not and I'm such a
hyper web server that more and more of
my work is kind of being twisted into
that but not but not really you know
what I mean and so a project I did as a
commission for my beam is called pizza
party and this uses a thing called page
scraping and now what a lot of people
don't know is that Domino's you could
order pizza online you could order pizza
through the website by just clicking it
and so pizza party is basically a
command-line application and for those
of you who don't know the command line
is this kind of like what computers were
like before they had graphics you just
had to type things in and that's how you
operated the computers and that's called
a command line and so pizza party is a
command-line interface for ordering
pizza from dominos which means all you
have to do to order a pizza is type in a
couple words right like pizza party well
I'll show you um to order a pizza
first first I have to log on to the the
server so give me a second
so what you'd have to type is pizza
party and then flags for what kind of
toppings you want and like a minus P for
pepperoni oh password this is the hard
part just got hacked so I changed it to
something very complicated okay good
before it was no it wasn't but I just
saw it's an easy password to remember
now anyway okay
pizza party okay so this is the manual
page which is basically help file for it
wait well so it says pizza party program
provides a text-only command-line
interface for wording dominus pizzas
from the terminal
this piece is intended to aid in the
throwing of pizza parties which are also
sometimes known as saw parties and so to
order a pizza
all you have to type is pizza party and
then the flag so minus PM x equals
pepperoni mushrooms and extra cheese to
medium and regular and this was
programmed with help from a program from
IMA Eyebeam named michael froman and
it's an intereting example of something
called page scraping which is basically
it goes to dominos it steals all the
data from dominos website right
reformats it right and then it throws it
back to dominos and it's it's called
page scraping and it's a common
technique for robots and bots to steal
information on the web and this of
course it's a common technique for us to
fake out Domino's web server and make it
I think it's coming from a web page so I
wanted to show it because I think it's a
good example of kind of appropriating
code in it in a kind of not so nerdy
assembly type way and the kind of more
fun internet way and I wanted to order a
pizza for you guys but Domino's just
changed their website and so now the
program needs to be updated because it
doesn't work right now I know right yes
they did
good point let's go to the pizza party
homepage and look at that this is a good
example of a cos mi web meme as I mean
the night I put it online the next day
the server which was a had crashed
because so many people had seen it and I
was number 2 on google for pizza party
the next day so
so let's go to pizza party homepage and
I could show you
and as Tom points out which was I think
one of the best things that happened
because of the project right sorry
my home pages
let's see news yeah so some some
computer scientist is like a filed an
official bug list report to like the
central open source bug list repository
which I was like was really happy about
because it means like my parties playing
with the big boys now or my programs
playing with the big boys you know and
this is also you know open source and
you could download it and do whatever
you want to do I should actually also
point out that when I'm not being hyper
lazy I do put all this code stuff online
so people could learn how to do it and
you know dot dot dot dot dot okay any
questions about that
are there any questions yes oh you have
to sign up for Domino's things
beforehand yeah so then you put your
login in a little like RC file and then
it it'll automatically do it I mean we
could do it so you have to pay cash at
door and that's why it's possible
because if it was credit card it would
get into ridiculous but cash it I mean
it's ridiculous that I mean cash a door
I mean I could just like like like I
won't I won't this was a very
conservative art project given the
possibilities the bugs are basically
like it's unencrypted which the Domino
site is unencrypted so when you're
sending unencrypted passwords over the
network that's a bet that's obviously
security far more to do with dominoes
than to do with my program also there's
a there's a file where you could store
your password and user name in a file in
your directory but it's never a good
idea to store your passwords and
usernames in a file in the directory
which you don't have to in this program
so it's kind of really common sense like
UNIX security concerns which I was like
cool wrote a terrible program well me
and Michael know I should say that
Michael did a good job and this is a
good example of a collaboration a good
collaboration that I did with
I beam Michael is a UNIX nerd and I kind
of knew about UNIX and he's like no
here's how you do a man page so stuff
like that is there any that I guess we
should just wrap it up how what do I
need to do to wrap it up anything okay
and then I and then I'll play a video
while everybody's leaving because
there's one more video I want to play
but I don't think we have time okay yes
I know yeah I know some of them like
we've met they did a Game Boy yeah did a
Game Boy thing where they put it back on
the shelves which I always thought was
cool so they did something very similar
yeah
Barbie liberation project or something I
don't know their music stuff so well
coming in the future yeah cool I have a
couple bands they pick construction set
the acid heads Jamie are kings on the
Archangel and the gay Beatles yes yeah
yeah yeah that that's what I would
showed at the binding on two projections
I barely remember it I didn't I didn't I
don't know yeah do you remember well I
mean elaborate on that I should I should
elaborate on that whole situation like I
just did that insulation at the by Neil
and I was just kind of like whatever to
the whole bike Reb to think yeah I mean
like I kind of have been you did the
whole thing so I have no idea no I was
like good okay that's a thing cool fine
with me you know what I mean like they
just came up with that if that's what
they wanted to think is about it's fine
you know cuz if you ask me with about it
well I think it's about I'm you're like
well it's kind of silly it's stupid and
you know I mean like I don't know
I'm not the best person to to get you
know I mean in terms of process I'm
really strict with myself and I could I
could battle with the best in terms of
process but in terms of cultural and why
I do what I do I have no idea yeah what
you're like what how would I okay that's
a good question you're asking what would
I do if I like stepped up stepped it up
a little bit hmm
well no I couldn't I'm not brilliant and
so working on these older things is easy
for me because oh Photoshop brush okay
so maybe I okay good good point um yeah
in terms of doing a hardcore low-level
stuff I couldn't but in terms of just
getting beat up I saw foreign making
comments on software yes I could and so
me and my friend Joe from base had
worked on a project called which was
basically Photoshop brushes but they
were images of the booyah tribe but we
called it the booyah technology
initiative and so when you went to paint
it just painted a picture of the booyah
tribe and so that's a good example of
what I would do I was I never did it but
I always wanted to make an Adobe After
Effects plugin that would be a booyah
plugin and so no matter what what video
you started with it would just turn out
to be a still image of the booyah tribe
and so those that those I think are good
examples of what I would do if I stepped
it up a notch
and pizza party I think is an OK example
well it kind of has the old end to it
but I'm not all at all afraid using new
stuff you know what I mean I just have
to step a little bit gingerly because I
don't it's really easy to get confused
it can get confused but most likely
would have be similar any other
questions yes
this is downhill I have a I have a lot
of good ideas I have a lot of cool
projects and I should say today I was
working on working on a project with
Frankie who's in the audience trying to
make a toaster that burns Tupac into
every image of the toast so but like in
terms of career or art I mean I can go
on a million art ideas last week I spent
like five hours on the one a9 train
trying to like stand right in the exact
right place so that the train would line
up with the train would stop and the
pole would line up with a wall and it
would say 666 so that will never work I
determined I gave up I gave up so but I
don't know I just keep on doing this
stuff you know I just do it all day I
just do it so I'm sure it won't stop
maybe one day I'll burn out or get wack
either one I don't know or I maybe I am
wack and I don't know it yes Oh a good
example a good question um the boy is
probably about to two or three years at
one point I got I got all my music out
and I started playing it again but it's
been a few years now it's really I'm
kind of I don't know it's like breaking
up but uh I do have a bunch of guitar
projects planned to which I'll keep
secret any other questions
so oh if there's no other questions out
of it yes yes once you have a header and
you just export it right once you have a
header oh yeah you get QuickTime Pro and
you once you have a header and it's
playing a video in your QuickTime Player
you just go to export and it will export
the video what I had to do for data
Diaries is I couldn't do it the hacking
way cuz the hacking way only worked with
playback and not export and so I the RAM
there
a program that will dump your RAM onto
your desk and I did that and then
attached a header to it went open it up
with QuickTime Player and then exported
of this video and then made DVDs and put
it on the web and stuff like that so uh
or yeah if you yeah anyway
anyway you can if you have something
playing a video you could usually find a
way to suck it out of your computer if
yeah yes I mean when I'm not being hyper
lazy I do put up a how-to and the source
code for my projects you know what I
mean or if it's just a binary just the
binary so I don't yeah I don't care what
oh well actually there's a bunch of good
examples like um I wondering where they
are but like some guy emailed me Mario
clouds on a gameboy which I thought was
cute there was another guy hey hello org
from I think Italy but I'm not quite
sure who emailed me soup my project
super mario clouds without the clouds so
he emailed me a QuickTime file of just
blue there's a kid Eric and I can't
remember how to pronounce his last name
who made bootlegs of Super Mario clouds
and sold them for $20 apiece on DVD so
there's been a bunch of examples of that
already and I really I'm like cool and
then he made me pay for it so but I I'm
like all for I was kind of really I
thought it was really I kind of am
interested when people email me that
kind of stuff you mean because I I kind
of I like it you know what I mean I
think it's funny so I don't and when
you're kind of appropriating stuff you
can't get mad when people appropriate
what you appropriated
yeah take that and that wraps up can you
put on the one that says four one four
three rave nine five so this is a video
I made with Frankie and we didn't have
time so I'll just play it while it's and
it's a infinite fill video all done with
Mac Paint so or a lightening paint so
anyway thanks a lot for coming I
appreciate it and hope it was cool